so who is coming over again is that his
nemesis rick has a nemesis i guess
who is he like a magic guy rick science
and he's magic
just help me smooth this over or this
guy's gonna become more trouble than
he's worth
richard get this over with
hello internet welcome to film theory
channel
667 on your interdimensional cable box
ladies and gentlemen prepare your
plumbus because rick and morty is back
and with
it are quick turn episodes analyzing all
the big brain high iq info in each
week's episode so if you want a hundred
years rick and morty analysis
hundred years rick and morty rick and
morty hundred years rick and hundred
years morty then make sure you click
that subscribe button because we'll be
having a few of these over the coming
weeks as new episodes roll out and i
gotta say this week's season five
premiere was strong
the episode titled rick dinner mort
andre you're just trying a bit too hard
to work those puns in dan harmon
is packed to the gills see that's how
you work in the pun
with everything that you'd want to see
out of the series smart sci-fi
humor fascinating new characters in
world building lots of crotch thrusting
and of course confirmation that a woman
named diane was indeed an important part
of rick's canonical backstory
if diane were alive today what would she
hook an established cannibal backstory
with me despite him denying it just two
seasons ago
you can alter anything you want about a
totally fabricated origin story and
mixed in with it
all is what i predict is gonna be our
thesis for the season an
outline of things to come for rick and
the rest of the family both through this
fifth season but also for what's to come
next in the series so um can you do me a
favor
sign this waiver i can't afford to have
anyone dying from ecstasy tonight as we
touch on the underwater adventures of mr
nimbus
gonna say that a lot to truly understand
today's mini theory let's actually start
things off not with this episode but
looking back at last season's premiere
in case you've forgotten we had
wasp rick fascist morty in an overall
theme of balance the show had just been
picked up for 70 more episodes and was
going through an identity crisis would
it retain its originally intended
episodic structure where
nothing really matters week over week or
would it lean into the more
narratively driven serialized structure
that gave rise to characters like evil
morty squanchy and tammy she died the
way she lived over serialized well last
season's premiere
actually answered those questions pretty
explicitly so i guess what we learned is
to split the diff doing a little of this
and a little of that yeah sometimes
we'll do classic stuff you know other
times we'll do whatever and for the rest
of the season the show delivered exactly
on that promise
some episodes were just random fun like
the dragon episode in snakejazz while
others were much more steeped in the
ongoing narrative like
rick's search for friendship in the old
man in the seat and the return of clone
beth and bird person in the season's
final episode
additionally there was this running meta
theme of what it takes to write the show
we had episodes like the story train
where rick and morty battle through a
literal version of the dan harmon story
arc and the vat of acid episode where
morty has to learn that life only
matters if there are consequences to
your
actions again an argument for
serialization of the show
all of it was set up in that very first
episode of the season it was quite
literally a thesis statement for all the
episodes that would follow it and
watching the season 5 premiere it feels
to me like the same thing might be
happening again now normally this would
be the point where i recap the story in
the event that you missed the episode
but in a brilliant twist
i don't have to do that the episode is
available right now
right here on youtube in its entirety
good job adult swim way to embrace the
future of content distribution i'm
linking to the episode right now down in
the description but hopefully it'll also
be showing up in the old recommended bar
next to the video anyway go watch that
one and then don't forget to come back
and watch
little old me immediately afterward i'll
be here i'll be waiting for you
[Music]
oh you're back great before we get into
the deep analysis i just wanted to call
this little detail out early in the
episode we get this line there are
suicide capsules in all of your teeth do
what you want with that no it's a bit
vague what exactly rick means by all
your teeth
like each tooth or each member of the
family has one but i did find it notable
that just a few scenes later we watch as
morty
loses his tooth in a fight against
hoovey's son japeth and not just
loses it but the camera outright follows
the tooth coming out of his mouth
could that actually mean that it's
chekov's tooth we have information about
capsules in
teeth set up by rick we are then
immediately followed up with a character
losing a tooth and sure we see that same
tooth floating around in the advanced
narnian civilization later in the
episode but i wouldn't be surprised if
later this season
morty is looking to use that capsule and
it's not there
that sort of long-term payoff has
happened in the show before to great
effect when rick and morty bury
themselves in season one
only for the information to pay off two
episodes later on one of our adventures
rick and i basically destroyed the whole
world we bailed on that reality and we
came to this one
and we buried ourselves and we took
their place and then pay off again
in season three nobody has to know about
that we can put it right back and
pretend we never saw it but all right
let's talk about some bigger picture
stuff shall we at the end of the episode
we have this monologue from jessica i
lived was i just the object in another
story was that all i ever was
could i be more it's obviously a
self-reflective meta moment for the
writers as they actually give jessica
some agency as a character rather than
just keeping her as the hot girl that
morty has a crush on but i
think there's more to it than that to me
just like that closing rant from the
season 4 premiere i think this monologue
serves as our thesis for season 5
being a side character in someone else's
story
of course this would hardly be the first
time that rick and morty's dealt with
this topic arguably one of the most
central themes and conflicts of rick and
morty is how morty often feels like he's
just a passenger in a story where rick
has all the agency
but here at the start of season 5 in an
interesting role reversal the episode
starts with
rick being the passenger and morty in
control and i mean that literally rick's
limp and injured body is stuffed into
the passenger seat and morty is the one
who's driving him home safely
and from that opening the rest of the
episode is all about both characters as
the
object in someone else's story for morty
he's just the mysterious
evil force that the narnian society has
spent generations trying to overcome
he's an object that they know nothing
about but something that compels them to
keep moving forward
to keep advancing he's a symbolic
figurehead in their tale
morty is their jessica except you know
they're not aiming to make out with him
rick and morty's always been at its best
when it forces the characters to
confront the consequences of their
actions but this episode takes it one
step further the story that plays out in
narnia is the consequence of morty's
actions but here we see it not through
morty's eyes but from the perspective of
the people it's happening to
it's a surprising and frankly great
reversal on the formula to make morty a
side character in what would in a normal
episode actually be
his storyline and because of this
reversal of perspective
it forwards the theme that jessica
explicitly talks about at the end of the
episode meanwhile after starting the
episode literally in the passenger seat
rick for the rest of the story continues
to be powerless thanks to mr nimbus who
marches in and takes control
face the wrath of your once and eternal
foe mr
nimbus sorry who is that my
nemesis it's weird right that of all the
adventures that we've seen rick have
over the years
fighting against threats big and small
that this guy this multi-cape wearing
aquaman wannabe would qualify as rick's
nemesis
the one who gets the all-powerful rick
sanchez to shut up
arrange furniture and mop up wine and
that's because the threat that nimbus
poses appears to be
emotional in nature these two go back
way back to parts of rick's backstory
that the series and rick himself have
been really shy to talk about
if diane were alive today what was she
going to establish kinetico backstory
with me because you're an embarrassment
to me and i don't need you anymore i
don't need anybody well maybe you hate
me because i am the only man to see how
far you have fallen i used to fear you
respect you now all that's left is pity
for a sad
drunk shell of a man too afraid to see
how alone he truly is
in the same way that bird person and
squanchy were able to get rick to lower
his guard
nimbus understands rick in only the way
that a former friend can
richard before you were my greatest
enemy
you were my only friend after all the
ultimate nemesis is someone who truly
understands you who knows your strengths
and your weaknesses who knows the things
that make you happy and the things that
cause you pain
that person could be your greatest ally
or your greatest enemy and this
continues a theme that we've been seeing
play out more and more in these episodes
the slow devastation of rick sanchez
he's saved not just once but
twice in this one episode once by morty
in the cold open and once my nimbus at
the end when his mechanical implants get
ripped out by cybernetic birds and it's
easy to overlook but this is actually
the third
episode in a row where he's had to have
been saved by jerry and beth in the
season 4 finale and morty
and summer in the episode before that
he's broken down
to the point of flinching when space
beth threatens to punch him
rick can't claim if god exists it's
[ __ ] me
anymore the show is constantly removing
his godlike powers now he's weak he's
lonely and he's losing
everyone around him he's quite literally
becoming an
object in someone else's story as
everyone else realizes that they don't
need him anymore
not beth well i was impressed dad he
saved my life no thanks to you
not morty um hey i don't know how much i
can help out tonight rick
jessica's coming over just to like watch
a movie or something all he has left at
this point is summer who for the second
consecutive time
ruins a season premiere get out of here
summer you ruined the season four
premiere
season four premiere you ruined it
grandpa i got the shell betrayed my
weapon
what do i do i have the shell should i
blow destroy the horn
what the hell you were supposed to
destroy the horn and that is where i
think the season's headed
rick sidelined constantly beaten down by
friends by family by the world a
devastated broken and lonely man who
once
acted like a god but now serves as a
background character in the show that
bears his name
an object brought along for the ride or
not because if we know rick we know that
he's too prideful to accept
that he doesn't want to be helped he
doesn't want to admit weakness as morty
becomes stronger and more confident rick
is trending the other way and i expect
this to push their relationship to the
breaking point this
is the season where rick and morty break
up or at least
is the one that sets the table for it
where morty stands up and no longer
wants to be a passive character in
rick's adventures or alternatively
where rick refusing to accept his
weakness rejects
everyone else so he can be alone and
prove that he doesn't need anyone else
it's also interesting because all of
this forwards the ongoing theory that we
talked about last year that morty
becomes rick
we already see it happening morty's
saving the day morty going into other
worlds and devastating them with
high-tech weaponry alone
morty striking out on his own adventures
he's doing
everything that rick used to do he's
becoming the main character of the show
dragging grandpa along for the ride so
there you have it the season arc as i
predict
laid out by jessica's monologue last
thing i'll say about this episode
congratulations to the writers for
showing some self-restraint here's an
entire storyline about jerry and beth
looking for some friday night funkin
with king of atlantis mr nimbus
totally optional but a remarkable option
to have i assure you very jealous
and they don't make a crabs joke or clam
media or
cephalus that is gold right there for
the taking anyway will i be right will i
be wrong who knows
all i do know is that it's great to have
something to look forward to
every sunday night so make sure you
click that subscribe button to join me
for future dives into everything the
show has to offer
and always remember it's just a theory a
film
theory and cut
you